So wheels,
let's start a little slow because I'm sure some people are coming.
So,
uh,
this will continue with abortion.
So we had two lectures ago,
we talked about abortion.
So the center of the abortion debate is when does life begin?
And uh,
luckily that's a question that biology can say something about.
Um,
what statement is the most common statement made on this?
Not Your own personal opinion.
Uh,
and not an educated opinion,
but what do people on the streets say mostly about when life begins,
but if,
what do you here,
right
at conception and
all right.
Yes indeed.
That's,
that's the most common sort of thing that,
that people say life begins at conception.
And so this is in the newspapers.
This is common.
This is an all or the media.
So George will,
how many of you heard of George will have famous Washington correspondent?
He's sinned.
You've heard of miss?
Syndicated like,
like everywhere,
everywhere quote.
It is a biological fact,
not a theological postulate.
That such life as a continuum from conception to death.
And then just before I was writing this lecture,
the first time,
most scanning the New York Times as I always do,
and there was a letter from the editor letter to the editor from a prolife
writer.
It is a scientific fact is any basic biology text,
we'll confirm that life does begin at conception.
The fetus is alive,
human being distinct from while dependent on its mother.
It deserves the full protection of its rights.
And that's,
that's what's coming out there.
Not only is it what people,
most people personally believe,
but is generally considered to be a scientific fact.
And I've heard this from prolife people in pro choice people almost
indistinguishably.
So the question is you've all had high school biology,
at least.
How many of you had a college biology?
A few of you.
And guess what,
that isn't what,
uh,
that isn't at all.
What a,
what a beginning biology textbook says.
And what does it say?
This is from,
uh,
you know,
they send professors free copies of textbooks.
So I just opened up one that they happen to send me and it shows something quite
different.
It shows life as a cycle and there's no start point here.
Fertilization is one of the events going around,
uh,
the cycle.
This is the essence of sexual reproduction.
We also know that there's asexual reproduction which doesn't have their stuff at
all.
And the cycle is the switch between a haploid genome,
which means one copy of each chromosome and haploid and diploid,
that each cell has two copies of each chromosome.
And when the sexual reproduction,
there's usually,
there's always some version of this one copy to copy a cycle.
And when you look in detail,
this is again from the same freshmen,
very popular,
very big selling,
uh,
freshmen,
college biology text.
It talks about three different sexual life cycles and in the most one that
you're most familiar,
one,
which is animals.
What happens is you start with a two and a multicellular organism organism.
That's you.
And then my Osas a certain,
the splitting of the chromosome so that the gametes get this as to an and being,
the number of chromosomes start from to end.
There's a process called meiosis in which pairs split and you get cells with
only one copy of each chromosome.
Those are called gametes or germ cells.
And then from another individual get a second end and you'd go back to the
deployed phase.
So it's again the cycling around between one copy and two copies of the
chromosomes.
Meiosis in fertilization,
knowing most animals,
it happens that the big stage like us is deployed.
But that is not a universal rule at all.
That here is a stage which is fungi and some algebra algae that have it the
other way round.
They go through the same cycle.
But now the big organism is the haploid stage where there's only one,
uh,
one copy of each chromosome and that's growing in your garden.
There'll be a lot of stuff like this in most plants and some algae you have a
third possibility,
whereas both are multicellular organisms.
There's the diploid stage is multicellular and the haploid stage is
multicellular and the cycle goes,
goes,
goes around.
So the basic idea is not that there's a beginning,
but that life is a cycle.
This is what,
I don't know what Your High School Textbook Trey.
I was afraid to go look at high school textbooks.
My colleagues who read high school textbooks aren't always horrified.
So I didn't go lower than a college.
A standard college textbooks.
And,
and again,
this is not the only mechanism of reproduction.
There's of course a whole variety of asexual means of reproduction.
So what kinds of things reproduce asexually with none of this
bacteria,
yeast.
Yeast to make your bread rise.
Yeast makes your beer used.
It ferments your wine.
And,
and he's used as fungi.
Between your toes.
They,
they,
they reproduce by what's the mechanism there?
Reproduction.
Budding.
They bud off my ptosis.
Um,
what else?
What grows in your garden that you eat?
Many mornings,
strawberries,
strawberries reproduce.
Oh,
all right.
You are,
you are disconnected from nature.
Strawberries grew up.
None of you have strawberries in your garden when your backyard.
Do you know who has a garden?
Yeah.
Why don't she has strobe has done,
they have runners,
they have what's called rhizomes,
they're called runners.
And you know,
and you have one plant and when it gets big enough and has enough energy,
it sends out a runner that grows the root and it grows up a strawberry.
And then it doesn't matter whether the runner is eventually cut and lots and
lots of things grow by,
uh,
by runners,
which has got another asexual form of,
of reproduction.
Again,
you,
since you don't have yards,
so pricker bushes,
the Bain in the northeast had a pricker bushes grow
runners.
That's why your garden gets just overtake.
You don't get your clippers out and be very brutal.
Your Garden just is overtaken by pricker Bush.
Brackin is the,
is the,
uh,
is the more technical term for that.
So there's a lot of stuff that reproduces,
but here the grass,
a lot of the grass grows this way.
Um,
and parthenogenesis anybody know who reproduces birth in a genetically,
what a lot of,
some fish to,
uh,
et cetera.
This fish worms,
all kinds of things reproduce a Partha genetically.
So,
um,
the idea that life begins at conception,
that life is any start point and it is really not what,
what textbooks are saying.
It's saying life is a cycle.
Uh,
the repeated organisms use different versions of the cycle and,
and many organisms reproduce asexually with no version
of that.
Okay.
This gets a little more interesting when you go from a freshman textbook to an
upper level textbook.
So a few years ago I
got an old copy of the uh,
the upper level.
This is biology to 41 re reproductive biology.
And I assume none of you have taken that.
Now it gets really interesting.
So this is,
uh,
the beginning of an embryo in your grandmother or your grandfather.
It doesn't matter.
And what's you and you know,
can you see now this is not,
can you see tiny little dots here?
Maybe if we turn off the light,
you can see them,
but it doesn't matter.
Believe me,
there's tiny little dots that this line is pointing to.
So this is inside your grandmother's.
This is your mother or your father.
When isn't ever,
that's your mother or father sitting in there,
an outside your mother and father in the Yolk Sac,
which you'd think it was just for eating.
There's an epithelial wall and epithelium,
just a set of flat cells like a skin that bound Oregon's and mostly covered
around in an epithelium.
And some of the cells in the epithelium start differentiating differently than
like a skin cell and they pop out into the center here.
Then as development goes on of your mother,
inside your grandmother or your father inside your,
your grandmother,
not inside your grandfather,
uh,
these cells crawl up into the embryo through a tube and they sit in,
they come to sit up here in the cells of going to become the rest of your
gonads.
So your germ cells start when a,
when a developmental biologists or reproductive biologists discusses this.
This is in a sense the start of life in your grandmother and your mother or
father's embryo inside your grandmother.
And then more events happened in the whole book is about those events.
Well,
one of those events,
many.
And so this is on page seven,
the beginning.
This is what happens in the beginning and when do we get to fertilization?
Well,
here's the next time code is and fertilization,
and this is on page 201.
So there's 200 pages of events that take place in between.
And fertilization is not the first or the second,
but it's the third kind of event,
even in this one chapter and it's purposes.
The establishment of diploidy,
again,
referring to the cycle of haploid diploid.
And just to let you know that fertilization is not an essential event.
It includes parthenogenetic activation as an equivalent step that that can be
done in the cycle as well as fertilization.
The differences between asexual reproduction and parthenogenetic is asexual
reproduction doesn't go through a having an a doubling of the chromosomes in
pathogenesis.
You in fact start with a haploid cells,
haploid organism.
And then that has mechanism for just doubling it without bringing in,
uh,
genes from somewhere else.
So it's like what a cell does is my ptosis is the normal state where sales
double a,
but then they split.
This is a,
this is,
uh,
a doubling of the chromosome,
but no snow split.
So you go from a haploid stage to a diploid stage.
And so while we're on Parthenogenesis,
I actually didn't know this till my until I,
until I read this.
Uh,
it,
it deuces with this format.
A zoned induces many remarkable changes in the oocyte,
the at fertilization,
but it's not essential for many of them.
And Osi maybe accurate pathogen by a variety of bizarre stimuli such as electric
shock,
exposure to various enzymes or to alcohol.
So you guys that think you're having a big role,
just bring your electric shock.
Her son,
it'll do almost as well.
And they,
they mimic whatever it is that the,
that the sperm does.
And what's interesting is the embryo,
the partner Jane,
this is a human,
this is a textbook of human reproductive biology.
It can undergo cleavage implantation and elementary sage or beating heart.
So mites and four limbs.
The,
the,
the stage at which a lot of the right to life for show you as well.
This is a human already actually can,
can happen without any intervention of sperm whatsoever.
Eventually in a human,
uh,
there are parthenogenetic animals and other organisms.
But uh,
in a human,
the embryo,
eventually the fetus eventually dies.
But apparently it's,
it's a deficiency in the placenta,
not in the fetus itself.
So it's quite amazing and again,
loosens up your whole mind.
But what is biology actually saying about life?
And it's not saying that it has a beginning and it's certainly not saying the
beginning is that fertilization.
Okay.
So having started this train of thought for myself,
we've done a freshman texts,
we've done an upper level text.
Now let's get into the research literature.
Oh,
I've just underlying these,
here's a research load.
This is science magazine,
which is when all scientists read it,
it has the latest,
greatest stuff you wish you could publish in it and so forth from 2007.
And it's about the Germline,
which is,
you know,
eggs and sperms and in the early embryo cells decide B between becoming Soma or
germline.
So when I showed you the yolk sac and your grandmother,
the Soma,
the body are the cells that stay in the yolk sac and form the lining of the yolk
sac and produce the enzymes I think which digest the yolk sac.
Those that migrate out become the germ germ line.
And evolution doesn't want the germline to go through a lot of divisions because
every division introduces the possibility of a mutation.
Every time you have to copy your chromosomes but you can get into trouble.
So it very early on in fact in your grandmother separates out the germline and
holds it in a band's for decades,
uh,
often.
Now again,
uh,
the important thing is this constancy of the,
of the germline for is necessary for species continuity.
That's all the kind of stuff.
And here again,
all kinds of events take place.
The only mention of fertilization in this whole introduction to this special
section,
this is special section just on this issue is where is is in one of the later
paragraphs.
Now I was being very pleased with myself for getting exactly the right things
that I wanted to show you and make this point that at all levels of scientific
discourse,
life does not begin at conception.
And then I stepped back from a little bit and what do I notice?
What's the logo up there?
The logo is a fertilized egg being fertilized,
right?
And they said,
oh my gosh,
that contradicts everything.
I'm trying to say,
cause it sort of marks out that the most important thing about this whole
process is fertilization.
But after my initial shock,
I get over it.
I look at and say that's a fake fertilization does not look like that.
And He,
and you've got to anybody who's taken a biology course and seeing these big,
there's first of all,
a whole lot of sperms.
This isn't just one for sperm sitting.
Like that's a whole lot of them.
And that would be a very nice trick to get a green and a red sperm together.
And I said that's a fake picture.
And you know that you're not supposed to do that kind of fakery in science.
But it turns out the scientists didn't do that.
But these journals is a mass produced things science sells millions of copies
all around the world.
So they have an art department and I don't know if you can see this,
uh,
but that picture,
is made by,
uh,
I've written this Getty images.
Getty is one of the big con,
uh,
Getty images,
visuals unlimited.
They're not limited there unlimited.
So this was put in not by the scientific authors,
it's not mentioned in the article.
So you're not supposed to take it seriously.
And in fact,
you know,
when you go after this kind of stuff,
I just looked at about two pages later and,
well here it is blown up so you can see that better.
And there's the exact picture from which it's,
it's com and you can see the flatness here and this little thing here.
And if you go back,
they show you the flatness here and a little thing here.
They've,
they've,
they've shown you exactly inadvertently,
they don't mention this at all.
They show you exactly where they faked it from.
And what they did is took this image and then took a red sperm image from
somewhere else,
lays them on top and gay and put them on there.
So,
uh,
yes,
I was going to say something about laying it on going.
I won't,
you can guess.
So what's the moral of the story of this last little bit?
Is it even prestigious scientific journals when they're not thinking
scientifically will lapse into the common parlance,
the society in which they live.
The important thing about reproduction is fertilization.
That's,
that's the common thing.
It's not a scientific thing,
but even scientists and scientific journals can,
can mess that up.
Okay.
So the whole phrasing of this debate in terms of when does life begin,
uh,
is a cultural hold from the many centuries when there was no scientific
understanding of reproduction.
So you have to think,
well,
when does life begin?
What is the alternative to it being a cycle from life's coming from life that we
now know is the case?
Well,
it's got to come from something that's not alive.
Right.
And,
um,
and then that then the question comes to very naturally to think life comes from
something not alive.
And he'd say,
well,
when does life begin?
And what is that called when you believed that life comes from not life?
Oh,
come on.
You had this in high school.
Oh listen,
dead spontaneous generation.
Right?
And did,
when did they,
do you remember when this was shown to me?
Not the case,
right?
Pastor was the final step in it.
It actually comes earlier.
The first guy was Francesco rating.
Well first let me tell you.
So what are the observations that make,
that made people think that there was spontaneous generation and uh,
take a caterpillar in them off.
So you have a caterpillar and it's one kind of organism and crawls around.
It puts itself up into a cocoon.
And if at any time,
not the very beginning and not the very end of,
in the middle,
you open up a cocoon.
A,
what you see is Google the,
the caterpillar has just sort of decay,
just fallen apart into,
into a goo.
But then you look sometime later and out pops is beautifully formed.
Butterfly and it doesn't look anything like the Caterpillar.
So the only reasonable way of interpreting this is that indeed the caterpillar
died.
It put itself into a little coffin and it,
it rotted,
it fell apart.
But that's very nutritious.
And out of this nutrition somehow came the butterfly,
spontaneous generation.
And that was what was believed,
uh,
about that.
Um,
he take rotting meat.
Where do you find flies coming out of maggots?
Where do you find maggots?
Rotting meat.
Rotting food.
So you do an experiment,
you go around,
you find some roadkill or something.
They didn't really have cars back then,
but this is all late 1,617 hundreds.
It changes it at that time.
So they take a dead animal and maggots come out of it.
Well,
what it is,
you can take the dead meat that you find around and put it in a jar and close it
up.
And if you haven't actually killed it,
very fresh outcome,
the maggots,
and you haven't led any maggots,
crawl,
crawl into it.
So that where the fish come from?
Well,
shallow,
most people who fish a lot.
No,
it comes from shallow water mostly.
And they grow up in the reeds.
So the fish come from the reads and then you get a little imaginative about it.
And if you read the literature from this era,
which I haven't,
but there's a lot of books that they do and tell you the juicy tidbits is
believed that it was possible to create mice by putting a dirty shirt and a few
grains of wheat into a sealed jar and letting it sit for 21 days.
So that scientifically tells you the gestation period of a mouse is 21 days when
it's made from a dirty shirt.
And,
uh,
I think some of you undergraduates probably know that from,
from experience.
So,
and as we'll see in a little bit,
human life was presumed to come from menstrual blood,
which is also dead.
And as a sort of a coagulation kind of process,
I'll show you what that was about.
So in everything from an insect,
uh,
to,
to a human spontaneous generation was,
uh,
the most obvious interpretation of what,
what,
what you could observe for many hundreds of years until the experimental
techniques really took over and people started showing that was not true.
So the first real break,
and this was Francesco Rady,
uh,
in about 1668,
who studied butterflies and he did a very carefully,
they hadn't really used scalpels before.
And so if you pull apart a cocoon without a really nice sharp knife,
uh,
we get more mush,
get much at all stages.
He used a scalpel,
cut it apart,
and he could see that early on that actually inside the caterpillar you could
see the rudiments of,
of the adult moth a happening and then you,
he could watch the development inside the caterpillar that was stunning to the
world when,
when he,
he,
we started talking about this to scientific societies that,
uh,
that are most,
did not come from the,
the rotting caterpillar but came from the cell.
The,
they didn't have the idea of cells back then,
but came from the body of the Caterpillar itself.
Then Spolin Zani when I went to high school at Spelman,
Zani was the hero.
I don't know why instead of Rady.
And he did the next step of it.
And that was the next century 17.
He worked around the 1750s.
And finally,
Louie Pastor showed that it was true also for microorganisms.
That was what pastor put the final nail in the coffin.
Now only animals,
plants,
insects,
which are animals.
But finally microorganism.
So by,
by the later 18 hundreds is when this idea of spontaneous generation for
everything alive,
uh,
disappeared.
And the phrase,
which was originally much earlier but not prudent,
was omnia ex vivo x over everything comes from an egg that there's always some
sort of a cycle of generation.
So,
uh,
so we've known for about 250 years that,
that there is no spontaneous generation,
that life is a cycle and they're in a cycle.
You can't point to a beginning.
So it's,
it's,
so it's very hard.
You know,
it's a sign of,
they're just the persistence of,
of cultural ideas that the culture is somehow hasn't caught on to that.
Now,
more educated people when discussing this in more detail,
understand that it's a cycle,
but they decide that the,
uh,
that fertilization is the final genetic sets,
the final genetic constitution,
uh,
of the fetus.
And therefore we can legitimately say point that as,
as,
as the origin point.
Uh,
but of course that's not true either.
Now we know him in great detail and I don't want to not of course in
reproductive biology,
but somewhere
I've got
what's going on here?
Oh,
not good.
Not Good.
Why is this stopped working?
Something is going slow here.
All right,
well it doesn't matter.
So actually at the time of fertile,
yeah,
there's hotel,
I'll talk about this this later.
I don't know why this is going slowly.
Um,
at the time of fertilization,
the,
the nucleus of the egg is still deployed and it's only after fertilization.
Then sometime later that the,
uh,
the,
the female nucleus go through its final division and that's random,
which chromosomes are going to be included in the,
uh,
in the embryo in which chromosomes are not.
So the final genetics,
the part of this step,
one of the steps of the final Jetta constitution happens after fertilization.
If you're getting defined fertilization as the entry of the sperm,
and then even further,
uh,
the female has two xs,
but in every cell,
only one x is going to be active.
So it again,
at a later stage in,
in fact way after this multicellular division has already taken place in each
cell in it,
one of the xs gets inactivated and basically crumples up and gets thrown away.
So the final genetic constitution is not set till a good bit of time after
fertilization.
And we can see this in Calico cats.
Calico cats have these sort of biggish black patches and biggish orange patches.
You know what?
We don't have that with our hair.
Our hair was,
this is,
it's usually all one color until it turns gray.
Uh,
but in Calico cats,
what you're seeing is at a certain point in development,
and you can count the number of patches.
So you know how many cells this comes from.
In one cell,
there's,
there'll be two sets of genes,
one which will have the melanin gene too,
to make melon and make the black.
And one will miss that and make an orange patch.
And in this cell,
the gene for orange turns off.
And,
and so you get a black,
uh,
the chromosome that has no arms,
the whole chromosome is turned off and you get a black patch.
And then this one,
the one for,
for melon and gets turned off and you get an orange patch.
And the number of patches tells you at what sales stage this process happened
because each of those patches are the descendants of a single cell in a somewhat
advanced embryo.
So the,
the number of genetic things that happen after fertilization is,
is,
is quite a significant.
And so even moderately sophisticated things,
uh,
that educated people,
you know,
believe about development and when it begins,
uh,
or just plain wrong.
Um,
so the only scientific,
uh,
response to,
to the question of when life begins is when does one say,
well,
4 billion years ago,
you know,
when the first cell in some slime of some sea somewhere or something,
uh,
life began.
And since then cells have replicated,
uh,
cells.
So in a sense,
since every cell in your body is the result of a split of some prior cell,
in a sense,
every cell in your body has been alive for 4 billion years.
You know,
there's never been anything,
anything dead in,
in the past of that.
Okay.
There's really more,
a very more interesting things about development
if I can get this to work.
Okay.
So development,
it is very,
very chancy,
uh,
repairing very,
very chancy,
uh,
operation there.
So this is the germ cells.
This is in a female,
but everything I'm saying about a female happens in a male.
And what happens is,
uh,
from conception,
this is the number of germ cells that they can count.
And they get up to like 7 million germ cells.
And then again,
before birth,
they start dying.
So,
for instance,
in a woman,
most of the classes is female.
You're born with this number of potential eggs.
Uh,
no you're not.
And I'm sorry,
and I'm one of the,
you develop this many eggs,
then most of them die right away.
And then as,
as gestation continues more than die at birth,
then they keep dying.
And by the time you're sexually mature,
there's only a very few left.
And we used to believe and maybe still believe that that's all the eggs you're
ever,
ever going to have.
You know,
and a similar sort of thing happens with sperms,
not quite the same.
Uh,
there's now recent,
uh,
research that sinks sure.
That there are some set,
some stem cells,
the kind of cells that originally produced all these oocytes,
that there some stem cells than hang around.
And that in fact,
after this period you can make females can make more eggs.
And for the,
uh,
the artificial fertilization,
artificial reproduction clinics,
this another really hot area of research.
Can we find those stem cells can for infertile women,
can we get them to now make a egg cells later?
So,
uh,
so that's one set of,
of a,
a real decrease in the,
in the,
in the potential.
So you start with 7 million potential eggs and,
but you'll opulate like 400 eggs during a woman's life.
And this is what solution looks like.
This is,
this is a,
an ovarian cyst proper thing.
And this is the egg that's coming out in there.
This guys,
this doctor I guess is trying to extract the egg for some,
one of the either experimental or in Vivo fertilization kind of procedure where
they can take the egg and injected a,
fertilize it externally injected back in into the theme that all kinds of
wonderful things
can happen.
Um,
now
after fertilization,
this winnowing of the,
uh,
continues,
very largely.
So there's a lot of genetic death though.
Now you have your fertilization.
The early events of really setting the genetic constitution have taken place and
often they don't work.
And it turns out that from fertilization in the next few weeks,
something like 80% of conceptuses die,
it's a quite striking phenoms called,
it's called a pregnancy wastage.
Wastage.
And humans have it much more than other animals and it's,
we don't understand why it all,
all mammals have the same process,
but it's really extreme in humans and there's nothing but theories about why,
why this happens and it's mostly genetic death.
So I told you that you start with a diploid cell,
the germ cell,
it's crawling out of the sack and it has two copies of each chromosome and the
chromosome unfolded as you know,
a huge thing and it has to fold itself up.
It has to pair,
they have to older clinic,
what is it,
26 pairs have to pair and then they have to split nicely.
Well that is a very complicated process that frequently does not work and what
you end up with is instead of one copy going each way,
you get two copies in this,
say ag or this sperm and Wa and no copy in the other one.
Then as events go on,
if you have two copies here and it gets fertilized by a sperm,
then you have three copies and that's lethal for almost every chromosome.
And if you have no copies and it gets fertilized by sperm,
you get one copy and that's lethal for almost every chromosome.
So the only chromosome which there isn't lethality is the downs syndrome
chromosome where you can,
I think it's 23,
you can,
you can survive,
uh,
with three copies of that.
And that's down syndrome.
And you know,
the frequency of Down's syndrome,
one in however many thousand it is.
And you know,
for every trip low,
that's called triple because you have three copies of that chromosome doesn't
know low,
you'll get no car,
you get no copy,
you get the,
or just the one from the sperm or if it's the sperm that has this problem,
you get the one from the egg.
So,
and that dies and every other chromosome dies is one of the problems somewhere.
There's some viability.
So you take the frequency of Down's syndrome,
you double it for that chromosome,
for the novel.
Then you multiply it by the 46 chromosomes,
23 pairs of chromosomes that there are,
and you get a number that just from this process,
which is called nondisjunction,
what the death rate of the oocyte of the fertilized eggs is.
And then there's all kinds of other genetic problems,
which I won't go into.
But the experimental Lee observe the empirically observed thing is that the
action of the 78%,
I say 80%,
but if you read the paper,
it's 78% of fertilized concept doses then die very rapidly of,
uh,
genetic death.
And,
uh,
the mother doesn't even know that she's pregnant because she doesn't know
anything in the first couple of weeks.
Her period may be a little bit delayed,
maybe not,
not,
uh,
delayed at all.
And you get really interesting legal and religious,
uh,
complications if,
if it,
well,
there's some theology here,
which you're gonna ask me about later if you want to know.
But Standard Christians is supposed to believe that resurrection is in the
flesh,
so that your comeback in the pretty much the same state that you,
you've died.
And,
uh,
if 80%.
And if you believe then that if you add to that,
that life begins at conception,
that means that the fertilized egg then that means that 80% of the,
of the,
of the embryos of the resurrected bodies in heaven are going to be in a test
tube.
They're there,
they're just a few cells big.
So it gets into,
into very serious,
uh,
kinds of religious,
complications.
It also gets into legal complications is just something a little out of place
here.
But,
um,
I can't remember what state it is.
It's,
uh,
a woman got pulled over.
So this state,
which she was on a highway and an Hov lane,
a high occupancy vehicle language proved to have at least two people in the car.
And she was pulled over by the cop because it was just her and the cops are
writing or ticket and she says,
no,
I'm pregnant.
And so there's two of us in this car.
And it became a serious kind of court case.
And so if legally one decides that,
uh,
an embryo or fetus is a person from the moment of conception,
then uh,
every time a woman doesn't have a baby or she drives,
you know,
the police are going to have to carry around pregnancy tests and examined this.
Um,
it's uh,
so the,
the,
the conclusion not that good,
but another point about this is anybody know roughly how long it takes to get,
uh,
get pregnant if you're trying five months.
Does that tie up with anything?
I just said,
if 80% of concept this is di,
that's four out of five and if it takes five months to get pregnant in what
month the other four happen.
Well those are the four months that you on average did not get pregnant.
And that though,
this is not proven,
but the numbers work out that there's really no other reasonable interpretation
that when a woman is having regular sex without protection,
not trying or not trying to get pregnant,
she gets pregnant every month.
And,
but four out of the five months,
the fetus,
the,
the conceptus,
the early,
the fetus dies barely.
And she doesn't even really necessarily know about it.
So,
and then in the fifth month on average outcomes a fetus.
So again,
legally and religiously that if one has the decides for themselves that life
begins at conception and you're,
and a woman is having sex,
that means every month,
uh,
a human being has died and there has to be a death certificate.
There may have to be in question of why did this fetus di did the mother like
drink alcohol or smoke or do something that might have caused that to die as she
causing the death of this,
this full human being.
And religiously you'd have to have a burial in Morrill master.
You'd have to do all the religious things that,
that attempt to death.
So the fact that it's not widely appreciated that 80% of conceptus has died
genetically
sits uneasily with,
with an idea that that life begins
at conception.
Okay.
So the,
so we're talking about the,
the,
the chances of the reproduction.
We saw that out of all these eggs that are started,
so many die before you're born.
And then even those that get fertilized,
not many of them get fertilized because most people aren't having sex all the
time.
You don't have four.
So there's 400 eggs that you aveo late and only a small fraction of those will
get fertilized no matter what your sex life is like.
So the big death fair then of those that do get fertilized,
80% of them die.
Then of course you're well aware from this course and once a child is born,
uh,
up until very modern times with his medicine,
something like a third of the kids die as infants or children.
So it's a very,
very chancy procedure and there's elimination at all kinds of stages.
Okay.
So I sort of hit you over the head over the idea that life is a cycle and that
is of course the only scientific way to look at it.
And when does the cycle begin?
You know,
can you even say something like that?
Well,
sometimes it's necessary to arbitrarily put a beginning to the cycle.
So when those come cycle is,
the seasons is the year,
the years a cycle of gets warm and then it gets,
it gets cold and different cultures choose different need times to start the
year.
So in our culture,
it's January 1st and why is January 1st it's close to the winter solstice where
the lowest point of the sun and the sun starts coming up after that,
which is December 22nd.
Well,
the calendar's weren't very good and they didn't get it quite right.
Christmas and new years in December 22nd or 21st I supposed to all be the same
day,
but the calendars were not good enough to do that.
Uh,
the Romans put at the ides of March,
remember Julius Caesar getting killed then?
And I just read the history of that.
They changed their calendar many times,
but during most of their period,
it was the ides of March,
which is March 15th.
Uh,
Chinese put their new year in February,
they had lunar calendar,
so it rolls around a little bit,
a Jewish new years in September.
And then that's a lunar calendar.
So that rolls rolls around a little bit and every culture decides how it wants
to set the beginning of the year.
It's,
it's conventional,
it's not a scientific statement.
It's whatever any of the culture decides.
And similarly with when does life begin?
Different cultures have decided different start points for this cycle of life.
One of the common ones is that life only begins after the worst period of infant
mortality.
As many emotional economic,
legal reasons that you really don't want to consider someone a human until
they've,
you're somewhat somewhat sure that the infant is going to stay alive.
So among the felony of West Africa,
Nigeria and infant becomes a person and has given a named seven days after birth
because that's the most extreme period.
The Navajo in America don't consider the child is alive again,
uh,
for this period of infant death and after delivery,
it's kept in a cradle board as a kind of an extension of pregnancy.
They'd comes out,
it's putting in a cradle board and that's considered the mother is still
pregnant
with the baby.
And this is very nice.
When the child laughs for the first time,
then it's considered a to B to be a human being and to be alive.
And then they march,
they have a big ceremony to mark this child's birth
in some cases and collect that.
You read about a birth happens at puberty and some of the New Guinea tribes,
uh,
the infant stays with a woman,
until puberty and even boys were considered to be women there.
They're,
they're just team of boys and girls are not differentiated.
Um,
and at puberty the males steal the boy away and they have a big,
uh,
birth ceremony.
You remember reading about this and in New Guinea,
um,
or upon becoming a mother even because it's so in traditional China,
which means up until the communist revolution and if not later,
um,
a woman has sort of two lives,
as you may remember from one of your readings that often a woman,
a girl child,
is not even given a name.
Number one girl,
number two,
girl,
number three girl,
they don't even get a name and they have sort of a a I existence.
And in,
in this,
these parts of Chinese culture and mother is considered to start her life all
over again at the birth of her first son,
not a daughter,
but the birth of her first son.
The mother takes a new name at this time and she has a show by that time have a
family name,
but the sun is never allowed to learn what her,
the name of her prior previous life was.
For all intents and purposes,
her life begins at the birth of her first son.
You read the article about the Egyptian woman,
remember what her name was,
um,
Gat.
And that means mother of Gab.
So again,
she takes the name,
which she has a whole life that starting a new,
a sense that when she has the,
the first son,
a mother of Gab.
Okay.
So the idea is that different cultures have very different takes on when life
begins.
Since it's a cycle and it's arbitrary,
cultures have a perfect right to choose whatever point they want for the
beginning of this cycle.
And even within a culture.
And,
and,
uh,
and I'm talking about culture of my friends who are largely no medical people.
They all have very strong ideas about when life begins,
um,
and the obstetricians and gynecologists,
uh,
because the vast majority of fertilizations do not result in a fetus.
And the mother doesn't show any,
any signs of it.
The mother doesn't know.
There's no change in her body.
You can't test anything about the body.
Uh,
the,
they consider implantation really early embryo sits into the uterine wall.
And at that point there's hormonal signals going back,
bouncing back and forth between the fetus and the maternal one.
At that point,
the mother's body starts changing.
And so they consider that,
uh,
the beginning point.
And when they say when you're pregnant,
they're not talking about fertilization,
they're talking about implantation.
And this causes lots of debate depending on where you define this.
Some,
uh,
like birth control pills and various devices are supposed to work after
fertilization,
but before implantation,
and we asked someone who's talking about beginning of life at fertilization and
you'd say that's abortion.
If you're talking to someone,
the beginning of life is that implantation that's not a abortion.
And this is almost never put out when people are arguing fiercely about these
things that they're just using different definitions of,
of,
of when things begin.
Another very standard one very important in western history is the ability to
move.
So back then,
starting back from Aristotle,
the difference between dead and alive was whether something had the power of,
of motion.
And that was called animation.
When you,
when you move your animated like a cartoon,
the cartoon is a fixed image and a comic book or something.
Then you have animated cartoons and that's where they move around.
So the motion,
and you probably heard the,
the quick and the dead quick referring to movable.
There's a famous book,
the quick and the dead and it's a very common expression that you're either dead
or you have the power to move.
And so,
uh,
Saint Thomas Aquinas tied together,
it actually comes from Aristotle.
We'll go back to that in a minute.
Tied in Catholic theology,
the ability to move with animation being alive.
And that happens at,
uh,
we now call it quickening when the mother can feel the fetus,
start,
uh,
to kick.
And because that's another way.
So you're going to have,
uh,
when the embryo implants,
when the embryo starts to move,
um,
the neonatologist are various in fetal viability.
You know,
can the fetus stay alive outside the mother?
And they argued that this is,
this is a sign of,
it's an independent being cause it can live outside the mother.
And so that turns out to be the most delicate thing is when the lungs can
function that a,
a fetus or a baby can live outside the mother as long as there's enough lung
function.
So for the neonatalogist life begins when there's enough lung,
lung function so that it can live outside the uterus.
Now neurologist,
I'm a neurobiologist of neurologists are closest to my,
I don't know to my heart,
but they're,
they're close to me.
They always defined the beginning of life.
You know,
when is someone human,
uh,
as referring to some mental capacity,
that they can do.
It might be motor response,
it might align with the ability to move that they're looking for motor
responses.
It might be brainwaves and might be ability to sense something.
A one variant of the neurologist's point of view has gotten to some extent
embedded in the public debate.
And this is when,
uh,
the fetus can feel pain and that's,
that's the point at which,
uh,
life begins for legal purposes and they perceive it.
And there's some research on this question on an awful lot.
It's very hard to tell.
And what you can take,
what you can determine experimentally is we know this pain receptors on the
surface,
like a few electric shock something and burn it or something.
There's pain receptors.
We can identify those,
we can stimulate those.
And we know the pathways by which it goes up to the CORTEX.
And so by the seventh month,
at the beginning of the seventh month,
those neuropathways are mature enough so that at least the information that
there's some pain has gone into the Cortex,
we still have no information of what,
if anything,
the CORTEX does,
does with that information at this stage,
it may not be ready to have any kind of response to it.
So,
uh,
I got go on.
But all of these different ways of defining the beginning of,
of,
of a cycle,
beginning of the cycle of life.
And it's,
it's up to you.
It's up to your cultural or scientific or academic predilections.
You can do it whatever you want.
All of those designations are equally legitimate and equally illegitimate.
And none of them are a scientific question.
Science will describe you all the stages of the cycle,
but it won't say anything about,
you know,
where you should say the beginning of the cycle is,
it's a chicken and the egg problem.
Just,
just very,
very simply.
Okay.
So now you have this thing that it's,
it's not a scientific question.
Uh,
there's a tremendous cultural diversity on it.
There's tremendous diversity within,
uh,
the public of one culture like ours about it.
So,
but the law has to define murder cause you know,
I can't go and murder a ta because they gave me a bad grade.
And so the law has to define,
some has to accept one of these points and there's law has had a variety of,
of things.
Wah w the law,
what the law likes is what they call a bright white line that it's clear to
everybody when you've crossed this line.
And since the development of the fetus in the uterus is continuous,
there's no particular point in time that you can say,
you know,
this stage is different than the day day before.
So no point during,
uh,
a gestation would be a bright white line that everyone agrees that either
happened or didn't happen.
Uh,
so what they,
the bright white line today is birth.
Everybody knows when something has,
has given birth.
And I'll tell you the moment that in,
in a Jewish rabbinic law,
uh,
it's even more specific.
It's when half the head sticks out,
then it's it.
That's,
that's,
that's when growth happens.
That's when the fetus becomes a baby.
And pretty much the courts have stuck so far in America with this conclusion
that that birth is the bright white line.
Everybody can agree on that.
There's also a fair amount of religious opinion,
everything that quickening,
that's another at least to the mother identifiable of hat.
No,
an outside person can't necessarily tell this,
but the mother doesn't eat it,
does not know whether she's pregnant until quickening until she feels the baby
kick.
She can miss a period.
But there's quite a few reasons for missing a period other than pregnancy.
So some of the earlier laws and,
and continuing into some of the abortion laws refer to quickening as,
as bright align as you can get,
but they're,
the mother knows it before everyone else.
Eventually you can put your year and your hand to her to a pregnant woman's
stomach and feel the kicks,
but the mother knows early.
But since that happens over in different pregnancies,
over quite a wide range of time,
over actually a month,
month and a half before,
uh,
the kicks become sensible.
Uh,
it's not a very,
very good,
uh,
kind of align.
Okay.
So,
uh,
we so far have that.
The,
the idea of the beginning of life is not a scientific idea.
It's very variable in,
in cultures.
And so we still haven't really answered the question of why this idea that life
begins at conception is such a prevalent idea in the west.
Again,
other cultures have very different kinds of ideas.
And one thing of course it pops up to mind is,
is it biblical?
Because so much of our culture comes from biblical ideas and well,
you know,
what some,
what is life?
What does the Bible say about when life begins?
Anybody know?
Nobody does all this fundamentalism in American,
nobody here.
Um,
well what is the cycle of life described in the Bible?
This is common and literature and the literature major should know this
dust to dust.
How many of you have heard dust to dust?
Yeah,
or something translated at,
at uh,
earth to earth.
Um,
uh,
it's genesis to some God formed man of dust from the ground till you return to
the ground for out of it.
You were taken,
you are dust and to dust,
you shall return.
That's the cycle of life.
And if this is the beginning of cycle,
at what age did God create Adam
does something moderately explicit method created Adam in his own image?
Well,
the image of God is not a two Sonata fertilized egg,
right?
Whenever you perceive the image of God,
it's more or less an adult,
uh,
a person.
And of course right away,
Adam was able to receive commandments to not eat the fruit and so forth.
And suddenly eve was born out of his ribs,
certainly not a to sell,
uh,
a cycle.
So,
um,
again,
in the Old Testament,
there's just no,
no support whatsoever for the idea that as a biblical idea that life begins at
conception.
And there is no in the New Testament,
the issue just doesn't come up at all.
There's no,
no,
no statement about when life begins.
We'll come to some statements which are very loosely interpreted in that way,
in a minute.
So very interesting.
Uh,
there's two great Catholic and then Christian because Christians inherited most
of the theologians,
Saint Augustine and Saint Thomas Aquinas.
You,
you've heard them all.
Saint Augustine came first 300 and something.
And in his confessions he's interested in this question and he says,
tell me,
God,
tell me whether there was some period of my life which preceded my infancy is
this period that I spent in my mother's womb.
Was I anywhere or any sort of a person?
I have no one able to tell me that neither my father,
no my mother,
nor the experience of others nor my own memory.
So here's one of the greatest Catholic saints and,
and Theologians who's of course read the Bible,
knows it backwards and forwards and he is very well aware that there isn't
information in that to tell him that answer.
So the conclusion is that this isn't a really a biblical,
the idea that life begins at conception is not something that comes from the
Bible.
MMM.
Okay.
I'm going to switch a little bit and come back to this,
these kinds of thoughts.
Um,
a little bit of the history of abortion and abortion has been known in history
as far back as we can trace.
The oldest reference is from an Egyptian hieroglyphs in tomb paintings.
So we're talking about the very early civilization.
As soon as people can write the writing about abortion by the time of the Roman
empire,
there were lots of references to abortion in the literature and there are no
laws against the Romans didn't consider it.
And in the,
as I've just mentioned in the New Testament,
it's not mentioned at all in this course,
nothing,
nothing was forbidding it.
So the New Testament,
the Roman empire or a contemporaneous of course.
And so the conclusion is that even though abortion was very,
very common at that time,
uh,
and used by all classes of people,
there were,
there it was not an issue for the new testament writers.
And
at the end of the Roman,
this classical period,
uh,
this Judeo Christian way of thinking about things comes into the mainstream of
Western civilization.
And there is an explicit passage about abortion in the old testament.
And anybody,
I don't call it out,
but anybody know at least at least one person ought to know what this passage
is.
One too.
So it's a very,
very minor number of people.
So,
uh,
the 10 commandments,
which you all know,
and you all know this passage also,
but I'll get to it.
Uh,
uh,
the 10 commandments are an exodus 20,
and the six of the commandments is,
you know,
you shall not kill.
And but what does this mean?
What do all these laws means?
So the following chapters,
there's an explanation of how to interpret these laws.
Uh,
there's various violent acts that men do and which ones are accepting you.
May you beat your slave,
may you kill your slave,
may you do this,
may you do that.
And there's a lot of jurisprudence in there.
You know what,
what are these one sentence,
10 commandments.
What are they,
how do,
how do you interpret them in particular cases?
Uh,
in Exodus 21,
for instance,
what to do in cases of murder.
What if one man hits another with a stone or his fist.
What if a man kills the servant water from and kills a thief,
et Cetera.
All of this,
uh,
exegesis.
And then in this package where it's explaining the 10 commandments hooding thou
shalt not kill.
Uh,
it describes a crime that is much worse,
uh,
than a modern abortion.
So in a modern abortion,
a woman for whatever reason,
doesn't want to be pregnant.
She goes to doctrines is please doc,
I want,
I want an abortion.
I don't want to be pregnant and here's 150 or $200,
or whatever it costs,
and please do this for me.
So it's voluntary on the part of the woman.
Uh,
this passage in the Bible describes a worse situation where a man violently
against the woman's will,
uh,
causes her to miscarry or,
or abort.
And this the quote when men have a fight in her to pregnant woman so that she
suffered a miscarriage,
man is fighting with a woman there.
So he goes after the wife rather than,
uh,
the husband when men fight and her to pregnant woman said that she suffers a
miscarriage but no further injury.
The guilty one shall be fined as much as the woman's husband demands of him and
he shall pay in the presence of the judges.
Now that is a,
is a standard HEBRAIC old testament law for property crime that you do a crime.
Uh,
everyone knows,
you know,
they decide that you actually have stolen this from the person and the victim
gets to say how much is proper recompense for this?
But the victim can't ask for anything outrageous.
So judge has to basically approve the settlement that if the judge approves
some,
that you steal something,
well,
I want that same thing back or 10 times as much or whatever it is.
It goes before a judge.
The judge approves it.
If the judge approves it,
it's paid that,
that settles it.
So that's what happens if,
if the fetus comes out,
if there's this miscarriage but no further injury,
uh,
that's the result.
But it continues to passage.
But if injury and sues you shall give life for life,
eye for eye and tooth for tooth.
How many of you heard that sentence?
Oh my God.
That's everywhere in Western civilization.
Everybody should have heard that.
That's called the Lex Talionis,
the law of the sort of thing and it,
and it's very standard retribution for retribution.
So it's very,
very,
uh,
interesting because it has an eye for an eye life for life.
Well if you're talking about the baby or the mother,
life for life could be either,
even though it says the baby is gone already,
you can still,
you know,
people fit a little bit life for life,
eye for eye.
And then what is the third thing that she was tooth for tooth that lets you know
right away babies don't have teeth.
It's sort of the one thing that they're missing.
And the fact that that this passage select that as the third thing to describe
is very clear indication that,
you know,
it's not the fetus they're talking about,
but it's the mother.
So this is very,
very clear,
uh,
both from that so that she suffers a miscarriage.
But no further injury then it's a property crime.
You've taken away something that,
that the father particularly wanted,
and the father's the one that gets to decide on it.
But if you do damage to the mother,
then you have to really,
really pay for it.
So,
um,
that's,
that's the most explicit passage in the Bible about abortion.
And it's totally clear that it's the life of the mother,
the life and physical health of the mother.
That's the important thing.
And the Jewish Talmudic law,
which is not the,
my book writing about it says,
if a woman is in hard travail,
quote,
enter life cannot otherwise be saved ones cut one,
cuts up the child within her womb and extracts it member by member because her
life becomes before that of the child.
But if the greater part of the head was delivered,
one may not touch it for one,
may not set aside one's personal life for the sake of another.
So again,
a very explicit statement that before birth,
defined as half the head out.
It's the life of the mother is the only critical thing.
But once that birth has actually proceeded,
uh,
then they are equal.
And you can't even save the mother's life in this case.
And what kind of procedures this is,
this describing that's become politically very important now,
partial birth abortion.
It's,
uh,
you know that the,
the right to life people are very much opposed to,
but here it is from biblical scholars,
uh,
talking about it as when a woman is hard to Availon,
there's nothing to do but that then you go ahead and do that.
So,
and of course this emphasis on the mother is exactly,
uh,
what is reflected in the supreme court decision.
I've given you the,
to read the Roe v Wade decision.
Um,
uh,
and again,
it's,
it's the mother that is,
uh,
that is the central interest.
But you may remember that the new,
that the Roe v Wade divides up pregnancy into three trimesters the first three
months,
the second three month,
and the third three months.
And the first three months,
uh,
completely at the mother's discretion.
The second three months,
the state can put some controls on it.
And the third three months after the sixth month,
then the state has a lot of lot of say in this.
So the Supreme Court decision is,
is kind of a balance.
And why did they decide to break it up?
Might not haves a why into three months.
And that probably again comes from,
uh,
is a biblical thing.
So one of the quotes that that right to life is use a lot,
and again,
you probably don't know this,
but to go talk to right to life or if you're pro choice,
whoever,
whenever side of this thing has a talked to Spock seriously to someone on the
other side,
it's very,
it's always very informative.
Um,
so there's this passage where Elizabeth is pregnant with John the Baptist and
then Mary gets pregnant and she goes and to see Elizabeth and John the Baptist
inside a Elizabeth's womb jumps for joy.
And have you,
any of you heard this passage used in these,
these debates?
Again,
just a few of you.
It's a very,
very standard sort of thing.
And,
and it goes,
it's a in a,
in Luke.
And when Elizabeth heard the greeting of Mary,
the babe leaped in her in her womb.
For behold,
when the voice of your greeting came to my ears,
the baby in my womb leaped for joy.
And so this is taken by,
by right to life people that the baby in the womb is already as sentiment,
a sentient person,
a full person.
Interestingly,
the story gives,
gives extra information.
Zechariah,
that's Elizabeth's husband.
They're very religious and they're old and they have no children.
But then God rewards their goodness by making Elizabeth pregnant.
It's a recast of the Jacob story,
or his life wasn't,
couldn't get pregnant.
And after these days,
his wife Elizabeth conceived and for five months she hit herself.
In the sixth month,
Gabriel was sent to announced to Mary that she would bear Jesus.
And the Angel Gabriel explicitly explains to Mary to marry that Elizabeth is now
six months pregnant.
And behold,
your kins woman,
Elizabeth in her old age,
has also conceived a son.
And this is the sixth month with who?
With her,
who was called barren.
And it's,
it's amazing because the Bible is not in and no other passages that explicit
about the stages of pregnancy and this repetition that at six months,
something special happens is very diagnostic and is,
is almost undoubtedly,
they don't explicitly say it.
The reason why the supreme court said it instead of enhance in these thirds of
the six month because that in a sense is in accordance with,
with one interpretation of these Bible passages.
So it also is scientifically reasonable because of the cords with,
uh,
the time when the fetus does respond to external stimuli that by,
by six months if something,
if the mother gets excited or something,
you can detect it in the fetal heartbeat and so forth.
If there's a physical bang or something that you can detect it in the fetus.
So at six months there's some sort of responsiveness,
neural responsiveness going on in the fetus.
Um,
the,
uh,
there's other passages and I put them all in your reading packet that I put the
exodus passage,
which,
uh,
pro pro choice people refer to if they know it.
And the prolife passages,
I put them on your reading packet and you,
you can,
you can read them all.
So given the basic,
the silence,
except for this explicit,
really accepted the explicit passage in exodus about the,
the criminal causing an abortion of this woman.
The Bible is really quite silent on this issue and yet it's a theater
theological we great importance.
So what has happened is the,
is the Christian theologians had to rely on the opinions of,
especially the ancient philosophers because when they,
this all started in the Roman empire,
those were their philosophers that were,
that were of importance.
And as I mentioned to you that Aristotle argued that the matter of the fetus
came from menstrual blood and,
but he had gotten interesting after the discharge is over.
So he thought pregnancy started after menstrual flow has stopped.
So in a cycle where there was a menstrual flow,
he says,
after the discharge is over and most of it has passed out,
then what remains begins to take shape as a fetus,
the female menstrual blood,
however,
is incapable of doing this by itself.
It must have the stimulus and the male semen.
They didn't know anything about a spurns at that time,
but they,
they of course didn't know about semen and they knew that intercourse was
required.
What it did,
they had no clue.
Male semen does not contribute to the material of the fetus.
He wondered what guided the development of the blood and fetus.
And he thought there must be some agent that is introduced by the sperm,
which causes this coagulating blood to uh,
to take form.
And he coined the Greek word for this,
which later gets translated his soul and the,
the western idea of soul really comes from this Greek,
this era's Tutelian image of,
of whatever it is that comes in,
in the semen,
uh,
that org is,
does not contribute physically to it,
but organizes this whole thing and much later in the,
in the,
uh,
you know,
1500,
16 hundreds when these issues became hot again,
this is one of the pictures of Aristotle's coagulum.
So this is is the womb.
And inside this stuff is,
uh,
mother's menstrual blood as,
as it is presumed.
And it's gradually getting organized where you really can't see much of the
organization in there,
but you can see is the blood vessels starting to form.
And if in fact you do a do dissections of,
of,
uh,
of a fetus,
the first thing that forms is the placenta.
This is the most obvious thing is the blood vessels of the placenta.
The mother has half the placenta and the fetus has half the placentas.
I hope,
you know,
and that that's where nutrients get exchanged and wastes gets taken out.
And then,
uh,
I guess in the original,
somehow you could see that there was a gradual formation of the fetus,
but finally,
uh,
the,
the fetus forms as some sort of coagulation of this blood under the influence
of,
uh,
of semen.
And these are,
you all know this story.
So we,
we now interpret,
um,
concepting concept is actually a very vague word.
Uh,
and I have in here,
but there isn't time read.
You're like what the Catholic encyclopedia says it isn't,
it's very,
very complicated.
It's not anything that,
that,
that you think it is.
But we interpret now is more educated.
What,
how do we interpret conception?
We use it as the same ideas,
fertilization.
Then if you make a distinction between conception and fertilization,
no,
I'm not gonna ask the opposite question.
Uh,
but fertilization has a specific current scientific concept.
Conception is an old thing that something undefined,
that an act of intercourse is needed and ejaculation of sperm is needed and
something goes on unknown,
but something goes on and that leads to a conception.
Um,
but our current interpretation of this as fertilization is often now taken to be
the traditional Western view,
the traditional Christian view.
But when was fertilization discovered?
When,
when we're sperms discovered,
I think you know this,
what's the name person who discovered invented microscopes?
Antonie van Lavan Hook.
You've heard of Lou and Hook,
I'm sure in high school you went through this.
He was the one that first found a little anamolecules.
He took drops of water and uh,
you know,
from ponds and looked at it and sold these little things swimming around.
And uh,
he defined them as anamolecules little animals.
And then he looked in sperm and they were the little things swimming around
apparently,
I'm not sure that this is proper history.
They,
the spice trade was real important back then and they want to know what it was
that gave spice,
it's Tangy,
tangy flavor.
So He's invented a microscope to look at spice.
So let's see.
So cause very expensive to get spice all the way from the Middle East going
through mostly Muslim countries,
which who charged a lot to passage it.
And so it's very expensive and they wanted to know this,
the secret of spice and they thought there was something in it.
So then his microscope to look at that.
But what he found was a little anamolecules and eventually looks at sperm and he
sees the out of molecules in it.
What does he do?
He interprets it as the same amount of molecules in the water.
Well the sperm is made of something,
the,
I'm sorry,
the semen is made of something and the sperm are little contaminants,
which are eating it up there.
They're just like,
uh,
like the,
the little guys he saw in anything that was,
that was writing and um,
so that,
that was,
uh,
a sperm,
but they didn't have any idea of,
of what,
uh,
what,
what it meant.
And then it was much later,
they didn't see human eggs and mammals,
even mammo eggs that you can see eggs with chickens.
Uh,
you can see eggs,
vin sex,
that's pretty obvious.
You can see eggs of fish,
that's pretty obvious,
but the egg of a mammo is so tiny that it can't be seen.
And so,
uh,
it was actually William,
this is a number of guys who are sort of gradually saw it and gradually realized
what it was.
But William Harvey,
the same guy that,
that,
that saw the circulation,
they figured out the circulation of blood,
um,
was one of the first ones to see an egg,
but they just knew about an egg and they,
and they said,
well,
that's sort of got rid of this blood coagulum stuff.
And he still had no idea what was in semen,
even though they saw sperms,
they didn't know that was in ag.
So it wasn't until 1840s that finally fertilization,
it was discovered in mammals.
And that is actually the physical matter of the sperm and the physical matter of
the egg,
uh,
comes together.
So,
uh,
the conclusion of all this is that the culture,
our culture,
and especially the religious parts of it,
believe that life begins at conception and believe this is a traditional idea,
that it goes way back to the beginning of Christianity,
even into the Bible.
But in fact,
the whole idea of fertilization only dates from 1840.
And so it's a very modern idea and the whole,
and then going further,
the whole idea of life having a beginning just doesn't make any scientific sense
because we know and have known for hundreds of years that that life is a cycle.
And so there's much more,
you have some very interesting reading on this topic and there's an infinite
amount of reading that you can do on it.
But that's all I'll say on it for today.